إليزابيث ، هذا محير من نواح كثيرة ،
دعونا نركز أولاً على مخاوف الصحة العامة
لأي شخص هناك يراقب
ما هو التغيير والعودة إذا كنت
ستفعل ذلك ، وهل نعرف لماذا
أريد أولاً أن أقول إن وجود
شخص مثل هذا لديه شيء
منشور إلى  موقع cdc على الويب
ثم تم حذفه قائلاً إنه تم
طرح خطأ في الأساس ، لقد كنت أقوم
بتغطية القرص المضغوط لمدة
30 عامًا ولم
أر شيئًا كهذا ،
لذا دعنا الآن نتحدث
عما حدث يوم الجمعة
على القرص المضغوط  تم نشر إرشادات تقول مرحبًا ،
لقد تغيرت الأشياء
ونعتقد الآن أنه من الممكن
أن ينتشر هذا الفيروس بشكل أساسي من خلال
جزيئات صغيرة معلقة
في الهواء ،
لذلك عرفنا دائمًا أنه إذا كان لدي
kovit وأنا أتحدث معك جون  وأنت
بجواري مباشرة وأعطس أو أسعل أو أبصق
عليك قليلاً ،
يمكنك أن تتعرض لضربة مباشرة وتصاب
بكوفينت وهذا يعتقد كيف
ينتشر هذا المرض في معظم الأحيان ما
قاله القرص المضغوط في الثلاجة  كان ay جيدًا أيضًا ، هناك
دليل متزايد على
أن هذه الجسيمات يمكن أن تتسكع في
الهواء ، ويمكن لأي شخص لم يكن
قريبًا من هذا مطلقًا
أن يمشي ويحصل عليها بعبارة أخرى ،
يمكنك نشرها إلى أشخاص على بعد
أكثر من ستة أقدام
إذا جاءوا  والمشي عبر هذا المجال الجوي ،
هذا ما قالته CDC بشكل أساسي ،
ولكن بعد ذلك بقليل قبل الظهر ،
عاد القرص المضغوط إلى ما قاله في الأصل
وهو أنه لا يمكن نشره بهذه
الطريقة ، لذا قاموا بتغييره يوم الجمعة
ثم قاموا بتغييره مرة أخرى
فقط في غضون الساعة الماضية أو نحو ذلك ،
ما حدث أنت تعرف أن أحد الأشياء
التي أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى التفكير فيها بصدق
هو أننا رأينا أن مؤتمر نزع السلاح قد
تعرض لضغوط سياسية
يتعرض لضغوط من الإدارة الرابحة
ليقول أشياء معينة
بالطريقة ونريد أن نطرح السؤال هل كان
هناك ضغط سياسي لجعل الأمر
يبدو
وكأن هذا المرض لا ينتشر
بهذه الطريقة بالشكل
الصحيح ولذا فنحن نعلم أنهم عادوا
إلى الإرشادات القديمة لأنهم قالوا ذلك
كخطأ
في نشر هذه المسودة ، هل نعرف ما إذا كنا قد
انتهينا
أم أنها المسودة قيد
المراجعة وسوف يقوموا بمراجعتها مرة
أخرى وسنمر في هذه المحادثة مرة أخرى
حول الوكالة التي من المفترض أن تكون الوكالة
الذهبية  معيار لإخبار الناس ، إليك
ما نعرفه ،
وإليك ما يجب عليك فعله
يجعلك تستخدم كلماتك
Switcheroo John أعتقد أننا ربما نجري هذه
المحادثة مرة أخرى وسأخبرك
لماذا في أبريل في أبريل كتبت
الأكاديمية الوطنية للعلوم
رسالة إلى البيت الأبيض تقول
مرحبًا أن هذا يمكن أن ينتشر
بطريقة محمولة جواً
ولست بحاجة إلى أن تكون فقط خلال
العطس أو السعال ،
فقد تحتوي على جزيئات
ستتوقف في الهواء ،
لذا إذا كانت الأكاديمية الوطنية للعلوم أ
كانت هيئة مرموقة جدًا تقول هذا
للبيت الأبيض في أبريل
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، لماذا استغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً من مؤتمر نزع السلاح
لتبديل توجيهاتهم لتعكس
ما فعلوه يوم الجمعة
، ثم لماذا أعادوا ذلك
اليوم ، لذا نعم  يجب أن يكون
واضحًا تمامًا أن هذا المرض يمكن أن ينتشر
بهذه الطريقة المحمولة جواً